peking will um jeden Preis Putin
irgendwie halten und befürchtet dass
dieser doch ziemlich missling lungener
Krieg Putin immer schwächer aussehen
lässt weil sie befürchten zwei Szenarien
also das nach Putin entweder eine
pro-westliche Regierung an die Macht
kommt dann wäre ich China auf einmal
isoliert das will China nicht es gibt
aber andererseits auch die Befürchtung
dass es dann halt ein Mafiosi aus der
Gruppe an die Macht kommt das schafft
auch unglaublich Unsicherheit also da
teilt China eine zu lange Grenze mit
Russland als dass man einen so
unberechnenden waren Nachbarn haben will
und in diesem Dilemma befindet sich
Peking